[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
the rich have left the planet literally
and you know figuratively and maybe one
day literally they don't care anymore
the rich are no longer invested in this
country running as a country and this
has been i mean private transportation
private schools private this private
that private communities private uh
firefighters kim kardashian and them
hired [ __ ] private firefighters to go
all over them you know go up in
calabasas they're uninterested in this
uh running anymore is it cut they're
more interested with what their friends
in london are doing uh what their
friends in uh the other other you know
in the united arab emirates are doing
they don't give a [ __ ] anymore they
don't care it doesn't matter isn't that
nice though
it's beautiful i'm trying to get to that
yeah i want to get to there i'm trying
to get to be one of those people so nice
who gets when you say private fire
firefighters oh yeah everything
wonderful i want that wonderful i want
that i do that on a small level right we
we all do it we all do it okay i have a
guy that does my [ __ ] lawn yeah that
does my pool can i do those things sure
okay i'm not i'm gonna do those things i
think you're trying to you're trying to
make yourself sound a little bit i mean
i'm talking about no i'm saying we do it
at small scale and only killing the
[ __ ] president
if he [ __ ] up yeah you're talking about
lawns we're talking about what if
kennedy doesn't run yeah what if he
doesn't run that's what i'm talking
about i'm talking about
oh there's a journalist who got what he
got tipped off well we're gonna hijack
his car remotely and send him into a
tree i'm not talking about you got a
pool guy i love that you got a pool guy
i'm talking about real operators yeah
blood blood when they're eating the
steak the blood drips out of they have
the taste of blood
and they love
the the the feeling of being able to
just manipulate and control
and yet it's nice to have a to have a
lawn person
[Laughter]
part of this is deeply unhealthy to have
35 year olds walking around the park
talking about
mickey mouse
yeah but it's deeply unhealthy yeah it's
crazy deeply unhealthy to take your kids
there is nice it's beautiful
it's great but to go there as an adult
is sick shame it's sick shame and you
know what now we're gonna have to start
raising our kids i'm like you should
have to wear it you should have to wear
them
fairy tales yeah how dark they were yeah
kids getting put in ovens eating people
what's closer to the world what's closer
to the world the wolf coming getting you
the old lady that looks nice giving you
you know like putting you in the oven
what's closer to the real world that or
a dancing teapot right
yeah what's closer to what's going to
prepare kids more for the world reality
those stories
or goofball [ __ ] it's goofball [ __ ]
i can do you do shut up
aladdin you go to any of the countries
that aladdin people are killing each
other aladdin should have been i can
show you the camp
we bombed it last tuesday
they have a different god and actually
it's the same god but it's a little
different understanding of how it worked
i killed your mom like that's what it
should have been
but it's instead it's just a fairy tale
oh [ __ ] who does this help
who does this help
you know come i've never gotten along
with the uh new york state
department of transportation
whose fault do you think that is i think
it's both i'm willing to take a little
bit of the blame but it's mostly i think
they have to also come to the table sure
and understand that yes my license has
been suspended 30 times
yes i have left the scene of accidents
yes i have not paid my tickets yes i
used to drive around in a suburban with
bald tires that would go all over the
road and when i was pulled over i had no
license nor registration or insurance
and a cop said once one of those i said
how about none of the three but i'm
white so he's like you nut
and i left and that taught me a lesson
that being white matters it's sad but it
does
um and i would just kind of but so i got
to pay them i think two grand
and i then i'll be back in business then
you're good to go then i'm good to go
two g's and you're out yeah but i just i
i should do it it's just i have the
money i should just do it but
principal no it's i'm just ubering yeah
i should do it i just borrow people's
cars without a license
and then if you get pulled over here
then you start a whole new system of
downfall in california well
if i get pulled over here you know i
like i like to be on my feet i like i'm
good when the pressure's on yeah when
the cameras are on i'm ready the
camera's on right now you're good no if
the cop pulled me over like i don't even
i don't even wait what do you know why i
pulled you over uh no sir i don't know
well because you were speeding
excessively with changing lanes without
a signal can i see your license and
registration absolutely sir let me see i
have my new york state this is a
non-driver id it's the same license
number you can go check it out now you
go see it suspended now you're back to
the car hey hi your license is suspended
wait a minute where
in new york you're from new york i am
how long have you been living in los
angeles i've been living here a while
sir i i just maybe my mail is not going
to the right location suspended i can't
believe this this is suspended yeah i
cannot believe it so you don't have a
california state driver's license i i
don't
driver's license do you have any kind of
license to operate a vehicle at all
well i have one in new york so i can
operate if you haven't suspended so i
thought it was in good standing but i
had no way of knowing that sir wait a
minute i have no way of knowing that do
you know ray kelly
are you ray kelly my father he's like
wait that's your father it's my father
oh chief of police ray kelly is my
father here's what i'm going to tell you
to do right now
here's what you're going to do you're
going to get back in your car okay
you're going to shake my hand you're
going gonna get back in your [ __ ] car
and you're going to you're going to go
home and you're going to say that you
you met the son of one of the greatest
civil servants that's ever lived okay
you know what new york was doing before
my father took it over okay there were
[ __ ] corpses on the street okay and
you know what they're doing now they've
got kids flying kites that happened in
the span of 15 years because of my
father and a man named rudolph giuliani
so sir yeah are you a white man sir yes
okay good what i want you to do do you
love this country more than anything
okay do you love donald trump more than
anything that's right so what i want you
to do is i want you to see who's an ally
uh-huh we're allies yeah okay cause
they're coming and you know we're the
first ones that are gonna go you're
right straight white men
so what i want you to do is get back in
that car and when you go home and kiss
your wife and kid you got a kid and a
wife sir i got both yeah i want you to
go home and kiss him and i want you to
you tell your wife and i want you to
tell your kid that there are still good
men in the world that realize that we're
in a fight you're in that fight aren't
you sir you bet your ass thank you hi
hitler and then he leaves he gets back
in his car
and ray kelly's not my dad but you see
he got so caught up in it
[Laughter]
do you know the one part that made the
most sense to me what the hell hitler
part
[Laughter]
people are bored and they need something
to do
people talk [ __ ] about me online none of
it bothers me you need something to do
what do they say about you they say all
these things are not true that i'm fat
uh that i'm loud it's not true all of
these lie i'll have taco bell which taco
bell's dog [ __ ] yeah taco bell's very
now you you say that i argue with rogan
about it it's actually tasty dog [ __ ]
it's tasty you're living in you're
living in the literal one of the best
places to get authentic good mexican
food good i know that's an annoying
cliche
but did they come here legally
no okay thank god um no i'm kidding of
course not um
i but you're telling me you know they're
building the wall out of doritos looks
taco's shell
[Laughter]
do you not like taco bell as as the
taste absolutely i it's it to me i grew
up with it though did you grow up with
it it's a nostalgia thing i had it as a
kid i was an establishment okay but i'll
give you another one i have dominoes as
a kid but i think that tastes like [ __ ]
oh it doesn't it tastes like [ __ ] it
really does that's not good pizza
dominant i'm not going to get the
chances good no nothing wrong papa did a
lot wrong
papa down did wrong
but you know i do have a taste for some
trashy food pizza hut you're gonna tell
me pizza hut is not good you know what
isn't the hut you know it's not good the
hot was making people laugh the first
intonation or was it because you just
wanted to be no making people laugh
cause i was good at it right so it's
funny yeah but outside of that once you
get over the idea that you can make
people laugh then it becomes that yeah
and then we want to separate from i want
to be outside i want to be outside i
don't want to be in a corporation where
it's like we're doing a 5k
i love prudential yeah i love prudential
security it's like what
i want to be as independent as i can
like these people that are like you know
all these institutions that you got to
go in and be like remax real estate
saved my life it's like what are you
saying
what what selling split levels in fresno
saved your life well then kill yourself
are your parents all together well my
mother is schizophrenic love that in the
mental institution and my father did you
visit you selfishly left no i'm kidding
um instead of moving in there with her i
do visit her once a week yeah once a
week i yeah when i'm in new york yeah
wow yeah she's doing good she is well
she's schizophrenic but
so what she's
you talk to a lot of people in our
business she goes she's only a little
further than they are
you know what i mean yeah there's a lot
of people that we know the end will not
be good
the end will be in an institution where
their day is planned for them yeah the
end does not end with freedom for many
of the people that we know
it ends uh in a very bad place where
they are looking at the ceiling and
looking at the ceiling and they're
heavily drugged i mean like somebody
will stand in a room and watch them take
their medication and go did you really
take it and they have to go
uh let's go like that to show that those
are no longer in their mouth
that is how it ends for many of our
friends but for a few of them it'll be
very they'll do well it'll be nice it'll
be nice how are you gonna end i don't
know i hope like that but also in a big
house in ballet
i hope it's the best and worst of both
worlds like i want it to be all and
nothing but they love that he's black
that's my point yeah that's a huge it's
a huge uh thing for a lot of guilty
white liberals going to bed and
their houses in the santa monica canyon
and they you know but they got 10 000
square foot homes but they're the good
guys they're the nice guys they're the
good guys we're the good guys they're
the guys that are concerned about global
warming but not enough to sit next to me
and row 18 of the delta flight they're
not that concerned they're still hopping
on a private jet right they're still
going to it's a tesla yeah it's a tesla
one of my favorite stories we the day
before i do rogue i go i go get a book
to get give him conspiracy book i get it
from uh people in the palisades they
have a 8 million home in the palisades i
opened the door
it's two old people standing i go what
do you guys do they go we're activists
and it's like
[Laughter]
are you really
are you really activists yes they're
right boy that's paying well
that's really doing well yeah yeah so
the money my family yeah came to america
in the 1600s really yes wow
they were they were witches and they
sold
uh
elixirs and they sold little things it
would light on fire
and and we grew that into a business we
started doing natural resources minerals
i have one point two billion in a trust
right now and how much can you access on
a monthly or i cannot access any of it
until i go back on keto now this is
something that is that a punishment yeah
no the attorneys have wrote that in
because uh my family has written and
this is illegal uh that they don't want
a fat slob running around la with their
money that was written down it's in
legal it's it's it's legal language they
say that's right a fat disgusting slob
running around l.a with their money they
would rather somebody who is a little
more svelte so i have to go on keto for
12 months of keto and i have to piss in
the strips and then i get the money and
then but will you get that as a whole or
do you get it still stipend out it will
be it will be siphoned out it'll be 300
million every four weeks which was fine
mm-hmm it's not great
but it's fine i use the word fine
what what do you think is your first big
purchase when you make a big chunk of
money
the cast of tiger king i will buy buy
all of them buy all of them what are you
gonna do with the with the actual look
at the business
oh the zoo yeah i don't know i'll
probably put people in it where's mad tv
where's [ __ ] like that right where's
stuff like reno 9-1-1 that you can't
even do now because half of the jokes
are reno 9-1-1 if you propose them in a
writer's room right now they call the
police
[Laughter]
where is this [ __ ] like i think you
think about that that's such a great
point when i think about nick schwartz's
character terry from reno and i'm on it
you could never pitch terry now do you
know that they would go that's
culturally insensitive you can't do it
yeah no you can't do it why does he
always have to be sucking dick i don't
get it
so what you have is a lot of unfunny
people that are that want that are
theater a lot of the industries people
that were like theater kids people that
were like like you were a theater kid
though you know i was a professional
actor who was paid holy [ __ ] sesame
street i toured around the country
you didn't go to theater school no not
at all no formal training no formal
training it's called training on
television
i had an i had an agent at seven thanks
um but no and i'm saying listen i'm
saying this to be a con to be funny but
it's actually a meaningful difference
yeah because when if you do it
professionally even as a kid it's
competitive and nasty it's disgusting
and if you do it in theater in high
school everybody's fun and supportive
sure and those people [ __ ] fail and
that's it and all the theater kids my
high school was like had one of the best
theater programs on long island you know
what it produced a lot of lawyers
because you don't you should all be made
to take gym and have a fire breathing
dike chase you around an auditorium and
like ms zanker used to look good time
for the fun run i don't look lowborn
here's the thing i don't look low
i look like it's very possible i'm the
i'm the unsuccessful child of a very
wealthy family you're like oh yeah that
that's tommy he never figured it out
right he's the youngest she's the loser
yeah oh that's a sweet kid if you had
trouble years ago yeah that's larry he
had a little incident yeah right i mean
i could very well be that guy nobody
looked at me and they're like well he's
he's he's lighting the world on fire but
i could be a comedian they're like maybe
that guy's a comedian maybe he's an
actor or maybe some kind of goon maybe
he created a show if if if i saw you
from a distance yeah walking around my
neighborhood like that
um i would say
if i was the rich guy in the
neighborhood i'd look at you and i go i
bet you he uh uh operates uh a company a
production company yeah he does
something yeah he runs a thing yeah he
does something that they don't respect
right they're like he does a thing that
we don't respect it's below it's below
below us like when you really talk to
entertainment when you tell you rich
people you mention entertainment they go
oh that's cute yeah yeah yeah
or i'm an agent they're like oh he's a
big agent but even still yeah they're
still like that's pathetic yeah of
course yeah of course yeah there's no
respect unless you work in an industry
of course unless they're like oh you
don't work in plastics yeah right so you
have no money
did you how many assassinations of
presidents have you tried two ranch none
four
that's where you get that mainstream
liberal kind of like we care about
everybody but the reality is they don't
this industry is essentially human
trafficking yeah i mean it's built on
the bodies of destroyed human beings and
you kind of see them you could see them
as they get out of their cars to sell
real estate or to uh wait tables and
they they they they're pensive and
cat-like and they're they're always you
know yeah and they they just look like
uh and they smell like cigarettes and
vicodin and the vikings doesn't have a
smell but it's kind of that chalky tough
feel and they're just hollowed out
husks of human beings and that's who the
business is really built on the failures
the demon there's a great broadway show
right now called the ferryman it just
won a tony for best play it's really
good you probably don't see plays right
but it's good i mean or but you read
books ever your book guy that's what i
thought yeah so but it's if you by
accident if you're ever whatever if you
have to do it but but if i'm in jail the
play right then i'll write [ __ ]
but
there's this great quote from greek
mythology where there's all there's like
a thousand undead souls wandering the
earth waiting for the ferryman to take
them to hell they can't even get to hell
or heaven they can't get anywhere the
kid would get in the hades they're just
undead wandering looking for the fermin
and that's kind of what i feel about l.a
yeah you just look at people this is the
undead this is the undead you look at
them and then some of them are doing
great
yeah then there's a lot of people here
where it's like oh you're just waiting
for someone to say that's enough now
that's enough
somebody goes up to as you're just
serving a cappuccino to some businessman
you're hoping he notices the shape of
your face and yeah lets you do something
i want you on a sitcom you want some old
nice woman to come in and go hey
hey honey and she's warm she smells like
grandma and she says hey that's enough
now why don't you come home
and then you're skinny and you look at
her and you go grandma
and she takes you home and you eat
biscuits in georgia the end
[Music]
[Music]